Nếu Mỹ vừa chính thức rất khỏi tổ chức E-Taythera với KFNO khác lại gần tảm mấy năm,
mà Mỹ là thành viên của tổ chức E-Taythera của anh cầu này.
Cuy định được tổng thủ Mỹ nô nợ Trump, nưa ra ngay trong ngày nông tiên trở lại nhà trắng,
và thẳng một năm ngoài.
Lên được quốc cũng đã sắc nhận là nhận được thung báo chính thức từ Mỹ chỉ 2 ngày sau đó.
Và theo điều lệ của VKFNO thì việc rất luôn, chỉ có hiệu được sau 1 năm.
Cái từ thử điểm thung báo.
Cuy định của Mỹ đã tạo ra nhiều lộn lại trong giới chuyên gia E-Tay.
Cái chuyên gia cảnh máo của định này của Mỹ có thể làm xuyếu lỗ lực hợp tắc E-Taythera trên còn cầu.
E-Taythera còn là Thì sẽ quốc gia và là VKFNO,
Nếu các bạn ổn nồng vào cho rất quan trọng trong giám sác sách sĩnh mấy,
cập nhật tư trận bác xin và chia sẻ rất nhiều.
Nếu không có những cơ chế đó, thời giao chúng ta cũng như nước Mỹ sẽ trở nên giấy bị tổng thương hơn trước các mỗi nè dọa của mình lại dịch trông từ này.